what's up reject nation i'm greg
and i'm melissa be crazy have you ever
seen the channel
caleb city no i haven't it is one of the
most
bestest channels in the world
comedy sketches all done by one
gentleman
and uh he's a anime fan gamer and he
just put out a video recently called
games that have
trash camera controls oh boy
i figure with you doing all the gaming
that you're doing
i'm really excited for this video
actually i'm not gonna lie
let's check it out and real quick i
wanted
you to tell the audience about
vixx vaporub what is it called
vix vixen i started a channel called
vibe
vixen on request for my community to
support the artists traditional and
musical so
every week uploading a new video
highlighting a new song and
artist wow the last one you took like a
minute and a half to say that i refined
it and now he's
20 that's amazing
why do i recognize this music maybe it's
youtube free
[Music]
yo why is it going in that direction
yo i can't see all i see is
get moved i know the struggle well
no oh great
stop right there
drop the power stone what
i'm genuinely confused on how i got to a
cutscene
[Laughter]
yes either you hand it over now or i
kill you where you stand
your choice kill me wait a minute
i remember you you're the murderer from
that alley
you'll never get this stunned you're not
that smart are you
beautiful i said hand it over
wait it's a fight
[Music]
i paid for this
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
it hurts because it's true
oh wow we're having a you're like you
have tears in your eyes
we started playing the last of us too we
had a new controller it was like a brand
new controller first time being used
right so i went into the game
easy transition so i'm like oh we're
playing now okay
but also there the controller was a
little
jacked so it would randomly do sweeps of
the area
yeah circle the character and i'm like
not doing anything so i'm thinking it's
part of the game and i'm like why can't
i see
it's terrible
well alyssa not that i really need to
ask what did you think of this video
your first caleb city video that was a
great intro video
to show a gamer i love it i'm gonna have
to subscribe when i get home
oh he's an amazing youtuber like i've
been seeing some of his
more popular ones from like a that are
like a year or two old interesting
watching his most recent i think this is
the most recent one watching how his
editing style has greatly
evolved oh yeah like it's pretty
impressive i mean obviously he must have
had some help with the showers in the
game and the camera is behind him
you know yeah some like that pan and
that zoom in
yeah it's great moving to the letterbox
the detail of having the subtitles to
make it feel more like a video game cut
scene the transitions in and out
effects the effects were great and even
the camera movement
to get the joke right and like the
camera move into for like wait what's
going on here
it's actually not as easy as it might
look to nail something like that down
you definitely would need a second or
even a third person for that but
like solid concept yeah
because it is true i i have this issue
with almost every game
at at some point in the game where this
starts to happen but i love that moment
where he's like fighting where he's in
the car like
how did i even get to the cutscene where
you have no idea how you even stumbled
here
and then it goes from cutscene back in
the game and he's in a fight he has no
idea that he's in a fight again i have
this issue a lot there's a game called
divinity original sin
okay have you ever heard of it no it's
basically d d but a video game
it's really really fun i have a habit of
wanting to explore
i like exploring and finding things and
looting bodies
i try to stay around my party i don't
know just one hair out of place
boom an important cut scene starts and
you're the only one in it the instance
for the entire party but you're the only
one that sees it i have to just sit
there and put my controller down just
wait for the rest of my party to get
there before i can even do anything
because
it's like oh i guess something's
starting now i don't know how i got here
but here we are
i play a lot of final fantasy 14. i have
this habit of working into the very wee
hours of the morning and i have to force
myself to stop so at like two or three
in the morning i switch over to final
fantasy 14
when you're in a raid or a dungeon and
you're you're off doing stuff
you can zoom in or be all the way zoomed
out looking at like everything but
sometimes you miss stuff so i kind of
use a halfway but you
constantly clip in and out of uh like
walls so you
never actually really see anything and
sometimes things just spazz out on your
screen you're like what's happening
oh now we're now we're fighting a boss
great all right that's why
i love that line there's two lines i
really love in this one that hit him a
lot he's fighting the
boss or whatever here and he's like i
can't even see my character
which can be a genuine struggle and i
love the last line too i
paid for this that feeling that gamer
that's such a gamble you take though
when you when you get a game
you know you're gonna spend like 60
bucks and then you're gonna
realize like oh there's so many errors
of this i've actually encountered some
glitches
like this with my copy of the last of us
too really i've talked about with other
people who beat the game and they didn't
encounter the same one i've had ones rob
like
i've i've gone through like in between a
bus then i'm suddenly like in in
white like everything's just white and
i'm like walking around and wiped and i
gotta find my way back to the bus
and then squeeze through it so it's not
the same thing as just a trash camera
control it's really just a glitch but i
landed there with some camera control
issues that i was having with the game
see
that can be really fun not necessarily
finding
exploits but looking for ways to break
the game
yeah my sister and i uh when i still
lived at home we would
sit down and do this all the time with
red dead redemption we would sit and
find ways to try to break the game
the best one we figured out was um
god i don't even remember how we
discovered this but if you went into
multiplayer
you could go to a tree you could find a
way
to um clip under the map and then it
would teleport you
and all of a sudden you would be in the
multiplayer
um like character creation but for
someone
else who was in the character creator
like someone who wasn't even
like in your network and you could mess
with their stuff
so we we it was all in good fun like we
didn't ever like
exploit it for the point of exploiting
it was just for shits and giggles we
wouldn't mess with whatever they were
trying to put on or do
and make it different colors or whatever
and the people like
you could tell like we couldn't hear
them but you could tell they were so
frustrated it was wonderful
the best way you're a terrible human
being terrible human
this is what i do with my time all right
guys we're caleb city
alyssa i hope you go home and subscribe
oh i will i'm going to show it to dan
it's
so funny subscribe to caleb city if you
haven't done so already
anytime this guy does a video he does
better than people who have full studios
for real though yeah that's incredible
what he does man click that notification
bell
last but not least
zach feiffel handsome gentleman i think
haven't seen his face one thing's for
sure man is a major
major gamer loves playing games i have
to tell you something i was going to
reply today who wanted me to cover the
halo infinite gameplay trailer you might
relate to an experience like this
i decided to react to it recorded the
whole thing did a whole commentary
come to find out mike wasn't on the
entire time
it was on but the wire connected to it
slightly unplugged and it was just
enough to block
the mic and just enough to block the
camera's
own mic internal mic so
i was like oh there's like no audio in
this 20 minute video
so anyway i was going to reply to you
today about it anywho
zach listen i looked up your name it
means god remembers
and god remembers all the sick perverted
things you do
so you start being a good person and you
do nice kind things so you can get to
the pearly gates of heaven one day zach
god remembers everything
but if your name zack you must be the
memory part of god since you're doing
the remembering for
god so can you remember everything this
devolved from something really sweet
into something else entirely really fast
who are you zack